let's focus on the introduction now
the first sentence is one of the most
important because it is the first thing
people read
so you have to work it and work it until
it is perfect and powerful
just as the title then in the
introduction
make sure that you answer what we call
the mrci framework
m stands for motivation what is the
motivation of your topic
do you explain why there is a real gap
in the literature but also why your
research question is an interesting one
a relevant one an important one you
could also explain why your research is
necessary
but why no one has done it before r is
for results
what are your findings that's the part
where you answer the research question
c is for contributions so how do these
results contribute to the ongoing
research or previous literature
contributions can be theoretical they
can also be empirical when you bring up
new data or highlight new phenomena
and they can be methodological if you
design a new method that is better than
others
or complementary to others and finally
i is for implications what are the
implications of your work for future
research
mrci should be your guide when writing
the introduction and the abstract too
since the abstract is actually just a
short version of the introduction
next let's take a look at the literature
review
keep in mind that most literature
reviews are at best very confusing
at worst downright boring so when you
write it
here are some tips to make a good
literature review
first of all while you need to have read
everything you should not put it all
down in that section
just write what is significant highly
relevant and helpful to get to the
research problem
always make sure that you have a purpose
you're not just listing references but
you're conducting an argumentation and
demonstration that's leading you
somewhere to the gap
to help with that a good organization a
proper outline of the review
are essential the literature review is a
delicate exercise in finding the right
balance between extremes
for getting references or being too
exhaustive
not being critical enough or being too
critical
not showing enough respect or showing
way too much
going back to ancient civilization times
or rejecting anything that's older than
five years
let's keep in mind that the literature
review is also a political act
by choosing whom you are quoting you are
choosing side in the research community
so treat carefully and make sure you're
not omitting any key reference
you